in the figure above triangle ABC is
inscribed in the circle with Center oh
and diameter a AC so AC is that I am
going to write over there if a B is
equal to a oh so this is equal to that
right over there AO is the radius so a B
is the same length as the radius what is
the degree measure of angle a be oh so
the main realization here is that this
length right over your AO the length of
segment a oh that's a radius so this is
a radius right over here it goes from
the center of the circle to the to the
circle itself to point a well this is
also a radius of a circle this is also
radius of the circle so this is going to
have the same length and I already told
us that a bee has the same length as a 0
which is a witch because AO is a radius
and OB is also radius is going to have
the same length this Oh B or B 0 and so
then what do we have we have an
equilateral triangle well what do we
know about an equilateral triangle all
of the sides are have the same length
but also all of the all of these
interior angles are going to have the
same measure so that angle is equal to
that angle is equal to that angle and
all three of them because they have to
add up to 180 degrees and you have three
equal angles adding up to 180 degrees
each of these have to be 60 degree each
of these must be 60 degree angles so
angle [ __ ] which is the one that they're
asking about is going to be a 60 degree
angle